[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh là là je vous lis un rang comprend
pas la musique c'est trop fort mais
c'est pour faire joli un pignouf de
corbeil silva tout fait planqué se
courait dans la tronche un coup leurs
baraques et un revers qui allez bouffer
400 plus comme l'acteur serait d'une
certaine date elle tient comme jactance
salut mon canari comme tu es beau tu me
dégoûtes tp également avec la lassitude
ou stagnante aussi d'alcan ep
territoires intéressés mais le tour du
quartier l'eau n'était pas légal le bal
en se fondant dans la gueule moralité
fait bien au foot et ghosts i iv dans
les stades mais balance par la fiole
débat par à la gomme ça y est vous avez
doute entendu
waouh
hé hé
ben
alors bon terme
tik tok vous connaissez vous moi pas du
tout mais alors au but mais 77 ans je me
lance vous me suivez allez hop
ça c'est un chat c'est l'animal le plus
étrange au monde ça c'est un pot de
fleurs le chef vous rentrez dans le pot
de fleurs dans le pot de fleurs on met
des fleurs on n'est pas un chat mais lui
veut rentrer dedans s'appelle pas un pot
de chat regarde là elle est coincée
voilà il peut pas rentrer en plus il va
avoir une intoxication de l'heure et
varrault craché que le co2 et peut finir
mal et là il force le passage du stress
on va appeler les pompiers voilà on lui
avait dit par votre dans le pot de
fleurs il force le passage il force le
popotin il va rentrer et la rogerie cros
et la table dans le carré vip dans la
boîte de nuit comme on comprend pas les
charges comprend pas cet animal il
[Musique]
non mais c'est les voitures puisque tu
avais pas l'air d'avoir bien compris que
ce n'était pas marrant la première fois
[Musique]
spies